remember I wasn't really I was just kind
of looking around and then after some
time
I looked down
and like a gorilla on a tightrope what
there's just a piece of [ __ ] balancing
on my shaft oh
[Music]
welcome back
very careful boys today uh unfortunately
we have Anthony back but there's good
news we have Chris Sosa
[Applause]
hey Anthony wasn't on the call sheet
should we pay him for today you guys
can't afford it anyway
[Laughter]
he's on the on-call rate right now I do
have barbecue and spicy buffalo for you
you could look that out says the guy who
literally went to McDonald's by himself
to give him his own food when we all
talked about wanting McDonald's you know
why I didn't get it for you because you
guys are all on a diet and I want to
support you
um you can look at me like look at a
crackhead yeah he's going Steve hasn't
been on dine since 2002. come on yeah
but Steve always tonight Steve always
eats uh you know good protein meals when
he's here because the sodium just [ __ ]
with my my uh yeah
acid reflux well I gave you guys chicken
wings
that I offered nobody took it and I
thought you did not give me well you
guys didn't take it well on top of that
that's on us I guess okay
um so none of you guys are gonna go eat
dinner with me tonight so I had to get
another meal because that food was gonna
be mine oh that's sad that's really sad
okay so so we're gonna talk about
uh embarrassing sex stories and Ryan is
going to kick it off Ryan from Quest
and on him because it sounds like no you
guys might have worship okay let's see
this is just my most embarrassment or it
might Inspire us yeah it might it might
unearth some hidden demons okay so this
story I'm about to tell you is like
everyone in quest knows the story it's
like my Infamous sex story everybody
knows yeah I told everybody as soon as
this happened because I I was so like
distraught so it happened while you were
in quest yeah before quest in rehearsal
it happened to me
um so like when I was on So You Think
You Can Dance and they sequestered us
and we lived in hotels
um my girlfriend at the time would visit
me and uh she was like so you think you
can [ __ ] that's good oh that's really
good
and there were three judges are you her
they
um so we were having sex in this hotel
hey you know yeah that's what you do
right that's a rock star life sleeping
stuff that's an optional part of it yeah
I just [ __ ] in a hotel you did 100
gross dude thank you wow the shadow guy
oh that was a rock star [ __ ] the shadow
guy so at this time like my ex during
this period was always asking like hey
like I wanna I wanna do animal I want to
do anal but I was like kind of like not
crazy about it I'm like I don't know it
doesn't seem like that's I would like
that I don't think my butt's ready for
this
Rihanna Maybe which which one's worse so
um so we're like we're trying to make it
happen it's a little bit like
you know tight strange
foreign to me a little bit
um getting in there and you know after
some like
like physical deliberations we arrive at
a pretty good stride words of
encouragement okay I'm like okay it's
going you know it's going pretty good
yeah like all right I can see why people
dig this like I'm doing anal yeah yeah
Look At Me Now
it's in the doggy position I'm standing
and she's on the bed you know that yeah
you know your stuff so we're going right
and like I think I'm so focused on like
um being able to like just not get
nervous I just remember I wasn't really
I was just kind of looking around and
then after some time
I looked down
and like a gorilla on a tightrope what
there's just a piece of [ __ ] balancing
on my shaft oh like a nugget yes so how
did that come out I looked down and it's
just like on top and I so you didn't
even smell it you saw it first I saw it
first and I instantly got so grossed out
that I pulled out like this
and broke up with their own
all the rest of it just came no the poop
came out that's worse than my anal story
all over the hotel bed which is
technically where I live and so I wasn't
a Circus Circus hotel room that would
have been nice
then they don't even notice she can't
feel her [ __ ] coming out or it's too
late you were pumping it you were
pumping it like like a like like you're
like ciphering gas out of a car ciphery
we just went in there and then why were
you let go yeah so yeah you say like I
finally learned how to relax my [ __ ]
yeah so wait when you pulled out the
rest of the
two girls one cup material came out
build out like uh like when you tilt a
bounce house full of kids did she turn
around
yeah
that started laughing and was like oh my
God but like I was mentally like so like
as soon as I I couldn't believe what I
was seeing I walked to the [ __ ] uh
bath to shower and I just started like
rinsing and [ __ ] and it was just like
the worst you were rinsing your day why
did you just go in the shower you're in
the seat because you know like that's a
[ __ ] faucet I just wanted to pinpoint
the area of conflict and so I'm like so
I'm like dousing my dick off and then
[ __ ] all over your [ __ ] all over the bed
and then she's laughing like she told a
joke on [ __ ] camel I killed that set
she's nailed her type five yeah so I'm
freaking out afterwards I just come out
of there I'm like yo what am I gonna do
about this bed
um I don't know why that's like she's
already calling room service well
because like I didn't know I was very
new to kind of hotels in general all the
time I was like 20 22 22. and then I'm
like are they gonna like find me or
something am I gonna get like my
permanent record we're the Hilton Honors
yeah a homeless man came in a [ __ ]
[ __ ] all over the place yeah so so I
bundled up I remember I bundled up all
the sheets like all of them uh because
it was like layers down and then I um I
went to the laundry room at this place
and just put it in the corner like
behind the machine
and ran away for like a week I didn't
have any sheets oh you just left oh yeah
I am you're just was that a hair
technology Hotel laundry room where you
took it to a [ __ ] dry cleaner it's
like during during this time when they
when they sequester you we I thought it
was a hotel but it was really just a
rented apartment oh that they're kind of
like using for the contestants kind of
deal they're Airbnb pretty much yeah
okay and did it smell like [ __ ] the
whole time the like I have never taken a
[ __ ] that smelled this oh my God check
in with each other after like yo like
well yeah attitude was just like she's
more of like a freak than I am so it was
kind of just like laughing and she's
like what's the big deal don't be such a
[ __ ] [ __ ] and I'm like oh my god
dude [ __ ] kidding you what I'll never
I'll never recover yeah I'll never
[ __ ] veterans place
[Laughter]
you're like I saw some [ __ ] man yeah
it's a shitty situation have you asked
her if she's done it before yeah she has
the that's why she's probably like man
this guy won't even [ __ ] me in the ass
she's done it before but like I remember
she was telling me like oh we should do
it like this like laying on your side
because it's easier to relax and all
this stuff but my dumbass I just thought
doggy is the way to go yeah that's like
the easiest way to do it but don't you
have to pray you would have poopy on you
no you're a [ __ ] plunger doing in
that position it's not it's not
recommended oh really and plus it's like
we didn't really prep because you know
like people always compare anal to porno
where they're like oh that's not the
real world like in real life you can't
[ __ ] eat macaroni sausages and [ __ ]
all day coffee and we're gonna do
animated and stop by Claim Jumpers
you're gonna see that mozzarella stick
later in another form you're at Claim
Jumpers you're like and they're like
will you be having room for dessert and
she's like oh yeah and I think I think
at the time at the time there were so
few stories like this among my friends
yeah at that age too yeah so like it was
like the worst thing they ever heard and
it was like so shameful and then they
all [ __ ] went through it they're like
uh oh yeah that happened to you
I don't know I don't think about anal is
it's just not it doesn't feel good
enough it's not [ __ ] worth that kind
of [ __ ] I've never I've never done it
since and like over maybe like 12 years
later I was with a different girlfriend
who was asking me to do that and I had
to tell her like
let me tell you a tales
and then after she was like I'm not
gonna pressure you no more like I'm like
thank you I really can't [ __ ] do it
anymore like I've had a uh shituation as
well but it was one of those things
where it's like we were just we're just
being nasty we're just going daddy blah
blah blah blah she's and like you know
she's like anal too uh I didn't know
that the code of uh which I wasn't even
thinking but it was like I went from
pink to stink and then stink back to
Pink oh wow you're a Easter yeah
[Laughter]
and she but she wasn't even she didn't
miss a beat either she wasn't like she
wasn't like whoa like that we were just
going we were just going just going out
bro yeah just so she was down she just
[ __ ] dip it back and forth like that
we were just straight up dunkaroos you
know did you ask her if she went to
Planned Parenthood after no well the
thing was is like uh she she did get a
uh like uh like a phone down there like
I forgot I don't know the term of it but
she did get a uh a situation useless
infection or you tell whatever it was
but like it's like really a bad odor for
like a long time it was like it was a it
was a fungus or whatever it was yeah
and I was like damn man I was like that
was did you blame her like man you got a
sticky [ __ ] what's wrong with you no I
didn't I never made I never made her
feel uncomfortable she really felt
mortified about it right like she was
just like yo like this is not but like I
was just like man we didn't know and she
was you know she she actually was on uh
antibiotics or like some medicine and
stuff like that but it was just like
damn man I well now you know I didn't I
didn't I didn't know but there you go
dookie all over the place too no I
wouldn't that it wasn't that how did you
avoid that part huh yeah how do you not
get the well there was no there was no I
don't know maybe she was already she
like takes this [ __ ] before and it's
like cleaned up you're okay
it's not shitty you don't it's not
always a [ __ ] situation you have to
always have [ __ ] come out afterwards
take a [ __ ] during yeah yeah I think
that's the problem the first time I did
anal that's why I didn't like it
um he's Vigilant the first time I
accidentally went in that's so
disappointed
the first time I accidentally went in I
got a wrong hole and I was like but that
felt so good
this is different and I was like she was
wrong haul out oh okay
um and I was like oh oh that's different
you know yeah one pump trump not even a
pump it was like a half a stick in and
like remove yeah but it's I I always
thought I always thought it was weird
because like like in same like in your
stories like it was always girls that
are like let's do anal and I'm like
really like I thought that's the movies
just love animal huh I'm like serious
that's so crazy well I guess I have to
try if you're gonna force me somewhere
yeah yeah yeah Thou shalt anal
I did it with a condom though because I
was just like I think that's easier
isn't it but I still had a little corn
yeah a little corn that got stuck to a
little corn a little corn and when I saw
that I just unrolled and I said I don't
think that's working for me I got limp
immediately dude I just knew that that
was the place where you're like it was
okay to have a oopsie in the poopsie
yeah I mean if I didn't have a bad
experience because I always loved
watching it in porn because I thought
that was like so cool yeah
cool so much heavy production in that
though that's what's unfair it's like
the when you butt [ __ ] in the poop seat
I I felt like that was like the premium
because if you see the format of a porno
right oh yeah it's the blow job and then
maybe you'll eat her a little bit and
like whatever and hopefully for a very
little bit and then you [ __ ] for more
than like two minutes nah because you're
a man you ain't a [ __ ] right yeah yeah
you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah you ain't gay you
don't get here too long
more than five minutes
will be sucking a dick
10 minutes in your game yeah
well when that happened did you tell her
huh did you tell her anything about that
Mac hey you're missing one I'm just like
oh I got a chronic yo one kernel down
baby we go to Cordoba tonight or
like kind of like in your situation I
don't think she would have gave a [ __ ]
and she was just laughing [ __ ] like did
we [ __ ] the same girl I don't know but
like the girl was like oh I'm [ __ ]
constipated I'm like really and then
later she like when we're doing it she's
like hey can you bang my like butt with
this little dildo like because we're oh
Pakistan I'm like all right [ __ ] it she
goes oh I'm so constipated and I'm like
oh wow that's hot better probably makes
it worse though right I don't know is
she trying to like I haven't [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] week I don't know it didn't work
out oh [ __ ] so um
this is one of those maybe Joe should
have went last a porn a porno Symphony
right the format is once you get the
[ __ ] [ __ ] then it goes to anal after
anal then you do the [ __ ] shot to the
face yeah it's a very sacred format
everyone knows the three act structure
yes yeah I totally reversed I don't I
don't know you went wrong in the face
I mean I've seen I've seen people divert
and then they they do that where they go
back and forth they're riding the dick
and then and then they go to the ass
[ __ ] and then they go back to the [ __ ]
they violate those rules the [ __ ] juice
I don't want the butt [ __ ] side
though after what I saw the reality I
was like no more butt [ __ ] yeah one
of my favorite gel porn stars he's like
I was loving this [ __ ] part like this
chick's getting railed in the ass and I
was [ __ ] loving it
she's like and he's like and just just
dude it's like [ __ ] her mouth and
stuff and then all of a sudden like [ __ ]
the guy's [ __ ] her ass and also this
guy's head appears and then the guy
takes his dick out of the shovel
and she was like
wait what just happened yeah oh [ __ ] I
took a turn you talk about the one where
the where the it was the it was a
transgender beautiful lady right and
then like they're all [ __ ] make it
now and all that and she's all sucking a
dick and [ __ ] and then he goes down on
her and starts sucking his dick too yeah
I thought I yeah I think that was that
was actually the story I think that was
actually the story those are very
different things it's the same idea that
Joe got Joe got caught off guard by a
Moment of uh homosexuality that he
wasn't prepared for I
I had no idea your dick was out you were
in it happens like a thief in the night
they say yeah I don't some
tell I just
again you're like hermaphrodite's
[ __ ] we need Joe to teach Like a Porn
master class we need Joe to do something
where he lets us know how to find the
killer horn on the internet it might be
the best point of the week or the month
maybe maybe porno pixel a month oh but I
don't know if anyone would actually want
to see that's a patreon maybe I don't
know if we did it on patreon maybe on
patreon then you could actually share
your list because he wants for the
Pervert and then you have commentary you
know yeah it's like a Spotify playlist
just a little nasty yeah and we're
asking questions about it I'll [ __ ]
ask you I'll sign up for patreon just so
I can comment it's like it's like all
the porn that Joe sends to our group
chat every month but actually he shares
it on patreon as well nine out of ten by
the way nine out of ten I'm pretty
vanilla good [ __ ] like I'm not that
crazy but everyone wants to know what's
Joe jerking it to everyone because like
a lot of guys like ass [ __ ] but like
for me I'm like
is that something you'd be willing to do
ass [ __ ] again no no Joe's porn picks
for whatever so tell me right now in the
comments that they want to see my
playlist top picks okay
they want to treat me like Zagat
or like Yelp or like TripAdvisor I was
like what is that I was like
yeah
I do think yeah yeah that's all I
thought that was a porn thing I was like
I've never heard of that all right the
18 minute 36 Mark we like to hear from
Anthony at this time
here we go we've been talking about ass
[ __ ] for like 18 minutes I don't know
where to go with the [ __ ] what's your
most embarrassing or weird sex sexual
incidents okay this is this is similar
to Ryan's where like a lot of the guys
in the crew know this and laugh at me
for it but it was funny
um I have to put my boy Lawrence call on
blast first in a great way hey Lauren I
was I was a big fan you know when I was
living with Lawrence Cal in our last
years of college
um one he's the guy who's notorious for
like he never closes the door when he's
in the bathroom whether he's taking a
[ __ ] or showering he doesn't dry off he
just air dries and put his clothes right
on never wears underwear he always had
his door open and a free person yeah
it's just free but he always had like
this yeah there's Lawrence there he is
beautiful guy wow does he just walk home
he knows he knows you're gonna want to
see this yeah that's what that is yeah
that's what that is that's true
um and he always had this like red light
in his room too and this one was like
you you know all Lawrence's girls too
have always been banging like just this
guy's just Top Notch somehow he's just
Top Notch he's a legend she pulls
[ __ ] Legend all right and he has this
like [ __ ] like red light his room's
all sexy and [ __ ] like that there's one
time and I was like [ __ ] man always pose
for all he's like does his thing so I
was like you know with my girl was like
man I gotta spice it up tonight so I
remember I got a little red light in my
my room right and I was like I'm gonna
turn this thing red once we get into it
uh I had a little control you know Smart
Life yeah and we started getting into it
and I'm like yo I'm gonna set the mood I
start turning the room red
and it [ __ ] kills the mood for her
she's like almost mad she's like what
are you doing this is just this is gross
satanic just stop right I was like I
don't know Lawrence
all the time I thought it'd be cool it's
like no never do that again
that's a very innocent question that I
asked myself sometimes you know it just
killed the mood for it yeah it just yeah
just killed the mood it was just not
right I wasn't expecting that some guys
could pull it off the red she was like
what are you doing that's exactly oh so
while you guys are about to go you
switched it then yeah I think if she
entered the room and it was already red
it might have been weird well it might
have already she might have already been
down with it or like you you eased her
into it yeah warrants is one of those
guys that you can't really copy what
he's doing unless oh yeah you gotta like
be him yeah no I get it he's got charm
to him yeah he's it's and it's the whole
thing too it's not a moment for him you
know it's not a move for him it's a
lifestyle red and green strobe and play
Christmas songs he's [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah yeah so so what do you do with the
red lights
out the red light out it was over it was
done he's [ __ ] a Frosty the Snowman
and
then and then Anthony tries to do the
same thing as chicken [ __ ] calls the
police
so did you try did you try to fix the
situation by like I could switch it back
to just regular Darkness yeah it didn't
happen that night
just from turning it on red yeah [ __ ]
Lawrence the knights where it doesn't
happen I gotta say that those are the
worst ones yeah yeah yeah that's where
it's like this is about to go down and
then you'll just jack off and go to
sleep no I just thought it'd be better
to have my boys laugh at me because then
at least it's a good memory yeah that's
wonderful well I bet you have a lot of
those memories these days huh
every day we laugh about your whole life
[Music]